لا يمكننا إخبارك باسمه ، من
الخطير جدًا إظهار وجهه
، حتى أنه لن يسمح
بتسجيل صوته أثناء تحدثه من خلال
مترجمه ، لكن يمكننا أن نعرض لك هذه
الصور البالغ عددها خمسة وخمسين ألف صورة التي
خاطر بحياته لإخراجها
سوريا التي لم يُشاهد بعضها
علنًا حتى الآن وهو يخاطر
بحياته مرة أخرى لمناشدة الكونجرس للتصرف
كيف تشعر في هذه اللحظة
بالعودة إلى واشنطن مرة أخرى ، أشعر
أن وجودي هنا هو شعور قليل من
الإحباط وفي  الإحباط في نفس الوقت
لأنه بعد كل
ما فعلته لفضح
ما فعله النظام ، لم نر حتى الآن
أي إجراء حقيقي ، اسمه الرمزي هو قيصر
، كان مصورًا عسكريًا في
دمشق عندما بدأت الحرب الأهلية في عام
2011.  أدرك على الفور أن
ما كان يوثقه آنذاك لم يكن
موتًا عرضيًا ولكن التعذيب ، على
سبيل المثال ، تم اقتلاع أعين العديد من الجثث ، حيث تعرض
معظم هذه الجثث
لجروح عميقة للغاية ، وكان معظمهم
يعانون من الجوع الهزيل  لعدة
أشهر وأيضًا علامات في جميع أنحاء أجسادهم
من الرأس إلى أخمص القدمين ، وكنت أرى
فكيهم وأسنانهم مكسورة بدلاً من
الانشقاق مباشرة بعد اندلاع
الحرب.يقول قيصر إنه قرر البقاء لمدة
عامين ونصف العام ليشهد جمع
الأدلة  وفضح ما كان
يحدث بالفعل في بلاده حيث يمكن تفسير أي علامة
على التعاطف مع الموتى على
أنها خيانة للنظام
سأعمل لساعات
لألتقط الصور وأقوم بتحميل الصور
وسأضطر لإخفاء مشاعري سأضطر إلى الصلاة
لذلك  دمعة لا تنزل على وجهي
لأنهم إذا رأوا دمعة واحدة إذا رأوا
تعبيراً على وجهي يظهر
تعاطفاً ، فسأقتل كما فعلت مع
عائلتي ،
كيف فعلت ذلك ولم أعرف
أنه هرب أخيرًا في عام 2013 و  جلب معه
ما أكده مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي على أنه حقيقي
ووصفه سفير وزارة الخارجية لجرائم الحرب بأنه
دليل أقوى مما كان موجودًا ضد
النازيين ، وقد نفت الحكومة السورية
مسؤوليتها.  ووصفت الصور بأنها
مزيفة قام سيزار برحلته الأولى إلى
الكابيتول هيل في عام 2014 ، حيث
أدلى بشهادته أمام الكونجرس
متخفيًا بنفس التنكر الذي استخدمه في
مقابلتنا ، اعتقدت بصدق أنه إذا كان بإمكاني
أن أمتلك الشجاعة لمواصلة
السنوات التي قمت فيها بالعمل  أنني كنت أعرض
حياتي للخطر كل يوم ،
بمجرد خروجي وأظهر
للعالم ما لدي من أن
ضمير العالم بأكمله سيتحرك ،
وبعد ذلك لم يمر خمس سنوات كاملة
لم يتحرك فيها العالم ، فلن أنسى أبدًا
ما  لقد أظهر لنا مشروع قانون العقوبات الذي
أثارته شهادة سيزار ،
وقد مرت الصور على المنزل ثلاث
مرات بدعم من الحزبين ، لكن لم يصل
بعد إلى قاعة مجلس الشيوخ ، لذا فإن
ما أناشده هو
أن يرضي الشعب الأمريكي إنقاذ الشعب السوري
وإنقاذ هؤلاء الأشخاص.  لا
يستحقون الكابوس الجهنمية الذي
يعيشونه في أحد المشرعين ،
جعل قيصر قضيته حتى هذا الوقت السناتور
ليندسي جراهام ليس فقط من منتقدي بشار الأسد منذ فترة طويلة.
غراهام أيضًا قد أذن الرئيس
ترامب وكشف لشبكة CNN أنه
يقدم قرارًا لإعلان
الأسد مجرم حرب للشعب في
سوريا ، نحن لا ندير ظهرنا لك
، أتمنى أن نتمكن من القيام بعمل أفضل
تحتاج الإدارة إلى القيام به.  بصراحة أكثر ،
ليس لدينا استراتيجية متماسكة
في سوريا وأنا ملتزم
بنسبة 100٪ بعدم السماح للأسد بالابتعاد عنها
والوقوف خلف أشخاص مثل
قيصر وسأجعل زملائي
في مجلس الشيوخ يصوتون حتى ذلك الحين.
على مكتب السناتور ميتش ماكونيل وغادر
قيصر إلى الخلف حيث
بدأ يضع حياته على المحك
لمحاولة إقناع العالم بالاهتمام
ومرة واحدة وإلى الأبد لا ننظر بعيدًا فنحن في
وسيقى الهولوكوست وب
د الهولوكوست قال العالم أب
ًا  مرة أخرى وأنا مندهش حقًا من
رؤية الفظائع القادمة من
سوريا وحقيقة أن العالم لا
يقول إنك محق في عدد
الأطفال الذين يجب قتلهم ،
كم عدد الرجال الذين يجب أن يُعذبوا حتى الموت؟
لا بد من اغتصاب النساء حتى تقصد
ذلك عندما تقول "لن تتكرر أبدًا"